i always knew i wanted to come back to  work full time but my boss didn't  believe even till the week i started  having my keeping in touch days well  what's that talk to us a bit about that  that's that might not be terminals  so keeping in touch days basically i  mean this is when i was having my kids  so it might be slightly different now  but it was five days that you could get  paid for on top of your maternity leave  to go back into work to do a full day's  work to see how you feel obviously  you've got to get the kids ready get  them to nursery blah blah blah but just  see how you feel before you decide what  your role looks like moving forward when  you go back into work  [Music]